why did they come after you let's talk
about the the reddit stuff sure
um so first tell us the story and then
we'll talk about what why it happened
i'm really bad at telling the story so i
forgive
please forgive me but uh so
on reddit i drew a series of comics that
did really well
uh in terms of votes the way that reddit
works if anyone doesn't know
you get upvotes and down votes um
upvotes means everybody likes your thing
your post and
lots of if you get a score of zero that
means lots of people downloaded it so
i drew a series of comics back in
december of 2018.
long story short one of them they kept
getting better and better
scores until one of them hit the
all-time record
and then the next comic i drew after
that oh well the comic was about
the mob going after comics creators i
have a
certain comics friend who was raked
raked over the coals by the mob and they
all enjoyed
taking him down so the joke was that hey
come be our new king
so i the new king of reddit
comics would sit on this new throne
but his dead body with spears that were
upvote
arrows were going through him and it's
like okay we're going to get rid of his
body and you can come sit on
the throne and be our new comics king
so the next comic after that was i was
sitting there staring at the
crowd and i'm thinking okay so how do i
entertain these people
and i drew as the punch line uh the hand
circle game
and if anyone doesn't know the hand
circle game is i guess it won't show it
but yeah okay hand sign
yeah it's yeah it's the upside down
though so it's
the joke being like i'll put it beneath
my belt and if you look at it then i get
to punch you
in the shoulder of course so it was an
anti uh joke
it's like i have no joke therefore i'm
gonna play the hand circle game with
everyone on reddit hey i get to punch
you all on the shoulder right
that was my punch line but they
interpreted it as the ok hand symbol
which was
prevalent at the time especially and
still is they saw it as dog whistle
they proceeded to basically scrutinize
everything that i've ever put up online
they went to my twitter they
started real they're like oh he follows
this that in person
jordan peterson ben shapiro or whatever
i followed left-leaning people as well
but they didn't care about that they
just said it's a dog whistle we
elected we we gave all these upvotes to
a guy who is
a crazy right-wing psycho whatever so
the next day
uh they basically downvoted everything i
posted
including um more comics it doesn't
matter
i tried to explain myself and i realized
on reddit you can't because if they
downvote you
no i'll see it they'll brigade you yeah
your answers are invisible basically
so basically long story short they ran
me off the website
so for a while like so so in the context
of where we're just talking they assumed
i was a crypto
alt-right i don't think dog whistler i
don't think that's true
i was in a high position i think it was
just crabs in a barrel
this guy's climbing also down that's
very likely as well because you said
that the previous guy was on the throne
they went after him
yes he i guess he did too good too
yeah they they wanted anytime someone
does too well on the internet or
anywhere in society it's like hey let's
cut them down just crap
yeah that may have been it that may have
been it and they just want an excuse
to chop people like that down so because
i kind of called them out on it
i said this is what you're going to do i
had already drawn the strip of them
lighting me on fire
and then i put it up the next day like i
basically told you guys what you were
going to do and you did it
yep and then i reaped the fruits of that
and my career was ruined
i wouldn't say so well it's a weird
story of how i got to where i am now but
um no for for several months i thought
that was the end
and uh yeah i was like all right so then
you just went the other direction and
started drawing joe biden eating people
and you know well that was an accident
but
you accidentally drew joe by eating
someone well that was what 18 months
later something like that so i had been
drawing comics
still on the side earning a few bucks
here and there
drawing indie comics basically i have a
series called mary sue that
got crowdfunded on indiegogo it was
pretty healthy i had a little comic
strip that
kind of got me through that year some
people were very kind to buy my books
and i found a new home on twitter i
guess by accident i was drawing
political strips and they kept doing
better and better
um and then people kept just saying hey
your comic strips
are better than your indie comics so
keep drawing comic strips and i
i draw my though i think which was the
biggest one because was it the the
the biggest one of all the time for me
yeah i'll never vote for you and he says
then i'm afraid you ain't black he sucks
out the blackness out of the lady and
she falls over
and now she's white and then you did the
kanye west but he like reverses it
because he's got
dragon energy yes dragon energy yeah
there's a whole series of these
and um yeah they're it's just a silly
it's just
dumb i don't think my comics are better
than anyone else's but i guess it just
tapped into something and people
responded to it at the right place right
time we were talking about that earlier
just drawing joe biden with like
his eyes are black and he's drooling as
he raises his hand and says i'm afraid
you ain't black
he's he wants that energy i guess yeah
it's
you know a political a good political
comic i think is timely i kind of
compare it to like a ripe fruit
it's only funny for a day or two and
then if i draw the comic too late it's
not even worth drawing because
i don't know what the joke is in this
one but i love it eating the
bernie girl yes it's bernie girl which
okay boomer or whatever her name is uh
that series all right so
it's it sucks to explain a joke because
it's not funny anymore but
the the joke if you put it on ian you
can see this part yeah i did i should
part it i drew that one
after uh he won what do you call it when
it's not super tuesday right right he
was he was chosen as the democratic guy
right yeah the nomination so the punch
line there is that he's absorbing
bernie support oh right so all i know is
you drew a picture of bernie right
of biden with gigantic crooked teeth
eating a young woman that's amazing
and then whatever that is in the bottom
right corner first he smells her
yeah he
he unfortunately consolidated all of the
bernie supporters at the time they
didn't want
nobody wanted biden back then we got to
remember nobody wants biden now
yeah no for real nobody does but all the
people voted for him are complaining
about him already they have to
get in line behind the champion to beat
the uh the reigning champion who they
hate the heel in this wrestling match is
trump and we have to
support anyway even if it's kamal harris
everyone knows it's going to be coming i
really can't stand this system where we
cult worship one
person in the middle and everyone like
circles around them and like humans and
that's
that's that's that's another
simplification uh the process started
with a ton of people
and there are a bunch of different
people supporting a bunch of different
people and then one by one you find the
one person everyone kind of
do you want to put on the throne you
kind of well i mean we're talking about
just
one of the offices of the 50 something
thousand we have in this country
so i would be happy to have like a
council of people we do it's called the
supreme court no i mean
as president like 12 people to run as be
the president but so so the reason the
founding fathers created three branches
is because
they made literally what you're
describing so i would like now the
executive branch to expand and become 12
people
functioning as the president well the
common citizen i think
doesn't want to they don't want to
really run these high-level
problems they you know they've got
enough problems on their own the family
work and stuff like that so
we have to choose people to make these
decisions for us hopefully they're
trustworthy
a lot of the times it turns out when
people climb to a certain level in
society it turns out they're almost
all corrupt for some reason that's a
weird pattern
but we like to choose people to do our
thinking for us because
who has time to micromanage uh
international affairs
i'm not i don't have time to study that
the reason we have one president
is that this is a specific branch
designed for rapid response yeah i get
that
so it's like if if someone's like i'm
going to fire a missile at you and you
had three presidents they'd be like what
do we do i say we do this no we do this
all the non-rapid response stuff he does
is a little excessive
maybe we could have a council for like
making policy or doing vetoes or
that's what that we do it's called
congress veto power it's crazy that one
guy
can veto something like you should have
to have a group of people absolutely
excited if that's going to be vetoed
it's two weeks
it's called congress then trump can veto
and then congress does a two-thirds vote
to override the veto but i don't like
yeah so you need a ton of people to
override the president excellent i think
one you should have to have a ton of
people
it's called checks and balances and it's
important to override congress's motions
too
the courts can overrule them too but
then at least checks and balances i mean
you would the supreme it's brilliant you
court maybe court of people we don't
have one supreme judge
no we don't know that's why we have one
supreme president it's a little dis
disgraceful it's designed it's it's
designed
very very well actually but it's
designed to run slowly is the problem
when you have a crisis you can't have
the slow-moving machine but that's why
you have a president
who can respond with war powers that's
the argument but that's literally why
they did it
they if when you have uh when you have a
direct democracy you get
tyranny of the majority and you get slow
response to a crisis
when you have a council of elders then
you know you have
the learned bunch but you still can't
move quickly now he's got the
supreme court nomination power that's a
little extreme for one person
but that should be a group you're mad
about is the democrats
when harry reid took away the two-thirds
requirement for for a supreme court
justice
confirmation blame them for it they
changed the rules
to manipulate the system to gain power
and it backfired on them
i think the auxiliary war powers that
george bush gave the president with the
patriot act success
yeah well he didn't give the patriot act
congress did yeah so the issue is
ridiculous the one person has that kind
of power so the problem isn't the one
person
it's the legislative body that you are
asking for giving power
over and over and over again endlessly
and that's why the approval rating for
congress is like
20 or something why do we have i think
it's both the problem is both i don't
like that there's like we
one person gets so much power the most
powerful person
in the world for four years and then
then the next person gets their
their their sloppy chops to go be the
most powerful person
that didn't earn it they just got voted
in simplistic view you could argue that
like
chuck grassley or mitch mcconnell are
more powerful no the president can order
a drone bomb no he can't he needs
approval of congress to declare war well
obviously the problem
is no not war or issue a drone strike
he can't yes he's not supposed to be
able to do i know and
congress had the power to levy war and
granted ridiculous power to the
president
that's too much power yes absolutely but
trump has been curtailed every step of
the way through lawsuits over and over
and over again
almost everything he's tried to do he's
getting jammed up i don't have a list of
his executive orders i'd like to get a
list of
they wouldn't even they let obama create
daca and then when trump was like then
i'll and daca you can't do that
well it's like well obamacare had too
much power too so so so trump has less
power
good i'm glad he got scrutiny in the
exact and in the office they went a
little nuts with it
but we the problem is over time the
rules kept getting changed to make it
easier for the ruling class
they wanted the rhinos and the dinos the
democrats the republicans their only
mission is
can i be popular more popular than the
other guy to get elected so i can get
the keys to the castle
then you get lindsey graham this is the
perfect example of this lindsey graham
says
trump should fight he needs to fight
this and i'm going to donate and i
believe everyone should fight
and then he goes into the senate floor
and he fist bumps come on harrison pats
around the back and walks away
he has no one because he doesn't
actually care about trump fighting
for re-election he wants people to think
it so that they vote for him and they
did
and then secretly he's like you go
kamala congratulations
they don't actually care about you you
don't like the system man they're
getting bribed no i don't like the
people
but we got one of the best systems in
the world the problem is we got a bunch
of bad people it's the worst form of
of government except all the other ones
that have been right yes that's that's
the was it winston churchill winston
oh winston and he's right it can be
improved
yeah we're kind of just you know
spitting about how
we have we have the process for
amendments the problem is
right now you've you've had over a long
period of time this war has been going
on this figurative war whatever you want
to call it the middle east stuff
no no no no the democrats like harry
reid in 2013 saying we're going to
change the rules so that we can pass
whatever we want instead of compromising
with republicans oh god
and then mitch mcconnell said mark my
words you will come to regret this
and probably sooner than you realize and
then
now trump's got three supreme court
justices through because they
changed the rules because they were
power hungry and said
i could negotiate with you as we're
supposed to do
no we'll just all agree to change the
rules because we have the majority
and congress can vote to give themselves
raise all they can give them
all time of course all in favor of
giving us more money
i all opposed motion passes
they do it all the time wonderful i love
it um
i think we're talking about this
yesterday i said i think we're on the
brink of um
getting rid of that that group of people
that representation
style and just start having more of a
direct representation system
i don't know but i don't think we can
well because
it doesn't work you would have to start
a completely new country on some
continent that hasn't been discovered
yet i would think instead of like
voting for someone that makes all the
decisions in their own head
you could just vote for your segment of
the of the decision
but they but like to say they make all
the decisions is ridiculously simplistic
but like okay 700 000 people vote for
one person and then that one person gets
their say amongst the other 230 or
whatever
now what if instead the 700 000 people
got one 230th of this
choice yes or no and then every 700 000
people gets one 200 that's just called
direct democracy no it's a rep it's a
direct representation
you don't you cut out those people that
can get bribed
i think corruption is going to find its
way in no matter what we do the the more
checks and balances we have in place the
better but unfortunately
when you get enough corrupt people into
a system they're going to invite their
friends to be
a part of it hey let's also be on the
take and they have all the kinds of the
creepy
they get all kinds of uh i learned the
word compromat uh last year
oh yeah compromising material man they
even if you don't want to vote for
something it's like hey we have a
this uh video of you eating uh captain
crunch and everyone hates captain crunch
and
we don't want that to leak do we so you
got to vote for you know
tricks and yeah it's
corruption is going to find its way in
no matter what i think these
systems have to be built with human the
human capacity for uh
corruption evil if you want to use it
that but who gets to define what the
word evil even means
um the more the more i'm sorry i think
the issue is that
the only people who really want to be in
office are those who want
power and regular people who probably do
a better job of it don't want to
bother don't don't want to do it even a
lot of
people who vote for a certain if you
have a vote maybe
they get a stack of paperwork like this
it's so thick and it's like who's going
to actually read through all that
rand paul rand paul i like him he's like
the only one that's a guy who i really
was small
back then yeah it's um but most of them
it's just like oh
let's talk about what the summary is and
i'll just vote whatever they don't
that's the whole point of a republic
anyways like i'm going to pick someone
to do all that reading for me so i can
go and live my life
i think i think we're starting to see
this wave i think both on the left and
the right has a wave of new
up and coming politicians who believe
what they say
yeah and i might disagree with with some
of these lefties but i respect them more
than some of these fake plastic pieces
of the castle democrats or republicans
so on the right you've got uh who's that
who's that woman who just want
one she owns the restaurant she's the
gun lady oh her name is lauren bobert
colorado yeah right there's people like
her she really cares
she got politically active she ran she
won and you can see that someone like
her a regular person who wants to do
something good at least
that's that's the impression that i get
compared to like these stodgy
suit-wearing
plastic politicians that don't actually
care you then have people on the left
like nancy pelosi
she does not want to do anything for
anybody she's awful
but then you get some of these young
progressives who are running and they
really want to see
legitimate change and they're adamant
when they say green new deal and
medicare for all they really believe
it's the right thing and hey you know
what i might disagree with a lot of the
how they want to go about it with like
weird intersectionality stuff but i can
respect them way more they actually want
to do something because i think it'll
help
people i mean they say the path to hell
is paid with good intentions
so you still have to push back on bad
arguments there's a big difference
between like nadler
and like one of these upstart
progressives to be fair i wouldn't even
put aoc in that category because she's
one of the worst
aoc is the perfect representation of the
keys to the castle democrats
she goes on social media she finger
snaps and clap backs and
and that's her whole thing i get the
feeling that she's not speaking her own
words there's someone
speaking through her well it used to be
that way it was uh was it psych
zykat chakrabarty and then he resigned
or something right so who knows who's
speaking through her now but
i don't trust it's it's weird because
it's kind of like taking a youtuber and
giving them
political power it's like they're she's
an influencer more than a
because her district is like tiny right
i mean she's got 700 000 people but it's
geographically small right but her
influence is uh monstrous throughout the
yeah throughout everywhere so she's more
of an influencer in terms of youtube
than uh she's a little district
this is this is what i'm worried about
in terms of how politics will happen in
the future
because she has so many followers she
can snap her fingers and raise an insane
amount of money that's it
that's maybe that's what they were
looking for there's some kind of the
internet age has
spawned a new kind of politician star
that that's a new and very scary
i mean we're at the whim of i mean you
want to talk about how scary trump is i
mean
he could say something at least he has a
counter-balancing force
whereas aoc she can say something
mobilize her whole
uh all of her people that are backing
her but
the biggest weapon that the right has is
calling her dumb and that's the
stupidest strategy you can
like you got the shapiro types and uh
crowder and all those people they're
calling her names and stuff it's like
bro
you're feeding her base you're making
her stronger by making
fun of her by calling her dumb and
whatever you have to take her
very seriously bite and i don't take so
seriously because it's silly but
someone but you know to be fair even if
you may have made a video or like if
shapiro
and or crowder did and they and they
said nothing to insult her and just said
you know and ben was like i think aoc is
absolutely incorrect on this point and i
respect her you know efforts to push for
the great new deal but you got to
recognize these things are wrong
all the left is going to do is eat it up
and say he's talking about aoc and
they're going to say really dumb things
like she's not going to date you ben
oh my god well remember when he asked to
debate her she said are you cat calling
me right give me a break but she
she makes her arguments on an emotional
level so right she
it's like playing checkers versus chess
man like
people eat up what she says because they
humans are fundamentally emotional
creatures the intellect is a thing
that's like you have to
you have to a be educated to even
understand what the rational people are
saying
you have to be willing it takes effort
it's like a higher resolution
way of perceiving the world but the
lower resolution way the nintendo 8-bit
version
is the emotions appeal to the emotions
this person's bad this is
this is a scary thing there's people
suffering and the only way we can save
them is by doing this
and never mind that it's going to
bankrupt the country it's the right
thing to do because it makes me feel
better it makes me feel about trump no
just in general like say
universal basic income or nothing i i
disagree with that i think there's a
million bad
there's a million uh side effects that
we don't want to happen because of ubi
let's say
um it sounds good on paper there's
people
that can really do a lot with that money
it sounds like a seven-year-old's answer
to a problem
if people are hungry just give them
money because then they can buy
food well that's a food stamp sar so
it's like yeah but but when
we're talking about like covet lockdown
especially
the government should just tell everyone
to stay home and not work and then give
everyone money because then they can use
the money to buy stuff
and then you say yes yes honey but then
if everyone's home who makes the stuff
you would buy
but like the foods at the store money is
a social construct
yeah no but like i actually got an
argument with someone who said if we did
a ubi
during like if we did like a ubi for the
lockdown then people would have money to
go to the store and buy stuff and i was
like and what would they buy
like what do you mean they'd buy food
and who would put the food there what
are you talking about like the food's at
the
store and i'm like people put it there
and then where does where does
where do the people get it from the guy
in the truck and where's the guy in the
truck get it from from the people who
put it in the bottles in the first place
and if you tell everybody to stay home
then you're not gonna have stuff to buy
it's really freaking scary dude it's
they want mommy and daddy back
it's yeah they're scared they are
de-aging
the whole country and we just want to
feel safe
and okay again they want us to be
dependent i'm trying not to use strong
language but like
they want us to be bottle drinking out
of the
yeah i i wanted to use enough to so i i
absolutely have to clarify
i understand there are essential workers
because that's the first thing they
always say when they're like dude there
are essential workers who are doing
these jobs it's kind of messed up they
have to so they should get a stimulus
too and i'm like
dude you can't have
every single job be essential the
bottling plant the dairy farm
the truckers the you know the
manufacturing for the bottles to bring
it there
the people working at the store because
otherwise you're just telling me that
everything's essential
i guess of course djs aren't or
something like that fine
so so but the problem is your money
becomes substantially worth
less and there's less to buy and the
other problem is that
because the supply chain got disrupted
in the initial lockdown
there wasn't any milk the dairy farmers
had nowhere to send the milk to because
the bottling plants had shut down
because they got infected with kovid
and then they couldn't process the milk
they just dumped it on the ground and
then the farms and all the crops they're
like we can't get anybody to pick it up
or process it so they just they they
tilled it back into the land and just
rolled it over
so these people don't understand the
economy
is okay it's it's a house of cards
almost i've
you know i know that's been used in a
negative way to mock the stock market
but it literally is like it's a very
very delicately balanced
supply chain for sure and if you take
one piece out of it other pieces start
to crumble and fall apart
and we saw that earlier in the year when
you couldn't like it was really
difficult to buy
basic things i remember because of the
supply chain disruption you couldn't buy
professional equipment
i was trying to get like a power cable
for a camera gone
all this is crazy this is only like two
months ago all the
all the video game consoles gone from
everywhere even still it's still
i hear it's just insane the most
essential isn't that crazy
i know you don't need these things but
it's like that who
why why why can't we get a playstation
because people couldn't make places
because the supply chain broke yeah i i
ordered a bedroom set
and they were like it'll be there in
february and i was like are you serious
i ordered it in september
give me a break so what do you so so
they give you money what do you buy with
it
and so what's going to happen is the
money is i guess potentially like what
mass deflation of some sort
if there's nothing to buy with the money
the money becomes worthless property
values are going to go down
because the only thing you can buy are
essential goods it's a perfect uh
perfect storm for a revolution i would
say people are depressed at home they
need
change they're broke they've lost
everything they're angry they need
someone to blame it on
and the rates are getting richer the
poor are getting poorer well no maybe we
should light some fires i don't know i
mean just
what they're doing yeah stay warm
somehow thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you